alors au delà des discours politiques
qu'en est il des populations sur place
comment vivent tels cette crise
ukrainienne on en parle tout de suite
avec un nous inviter sur ce plateau donc
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france bons soient régis merci d'être
avec nous et avec nous également jérôme
sessini reporter photographe membre de
magnum photos bonsoir jérôme sessini on
est passionnément ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes membre donc je le
disais de même photo prix pierre et
alexandra boulât plusieurs fois lauréat
du world press photo et surtout vous
avez couvert de nombreux conflits et des
zones de guerre dont évidemment
l'ukraine vous avez publié ce livre
alors je sais pas si on le voit la
caméra c'est pas évident in her
disorders l'ukraine
2014-2017 à vous documenter ainsi six
années guerre aux portes de l'europe et
on découvre clairement ces instants de
vie où l'humain est le coeur de votre
travail justement l'humain ça nous
intéressait parce que on voit toujours
les discours des dirigeants prendre
voilà parler du sort d'un pays on parle
un petit peu moins des populations ce
sont les grands oubliés finalement de ce
qui se joue en ce moment les populations
absolument - c'est d'ailleurs toute la
mon approche photographique dans ce
travail était justement de me mettre à
hauteur du main est
bon c'est difficile surtout avec la la
question ukrainienne est là aussi deux
pas
il ya beaucoup propagande de part et
d'autre donc moi je voulais évacuer ce
problème et raconter vraiment la vie le
quotidien des humains d'abord un maidan
c'est commencer et ensuite j'ai suivi le
mouvement ce qui est devenu une vraie
guerre ensuite dans l'est vous avez
passé des mois voire des années en
ukraine vous avez vécu justement cette
crise maiden le soulèvement
oui savoir d'ailleurs sur sur les photos
quand vous nous parlez en découvrir vos
photos également vous n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à les commenter oui alors là
il s'agit c'est une photo que j'ai prise
à mario paul avances des deux membres
d'un bataillon de miliciens d'ukrainiens
bataillon azoff qui était dans un moment
de détente sur la plage on va la revoir
si la régie veut bien nous remettre
cette photo / sur la plage de ces deux
hommes
voilà la régie on
voit là pour ça ça va revenir ça va
revenir enfin oui et donc un moment
détente de ces deux hommes oui ces deux
hommes d'un bataillon de volontaires qui
se battent pour
kiev pour le gouvernement ukrainien et
qu'ils étaient dans leurs casernes et
qui à un moment donné sont sortis pour
se détendre et l'ong seul moyen de
s'amuser ce avec une arme voilà
régis c'est vrai que cette expérience
est importante parce que on a du mal
souvent quand on parle de ce qu'on fit
s'imaginer ce que vivre ces gens en
ukraine qu ils sont d'ailleurs souvent
extrêmement divisés c'est un pays
extrêmement fracture est lancé à payer
un enregistrement fracture mais en même
temps qu'il ya eu une destinée commune
aussi on peut pas croire que l'est et
l'ouest si on peut les diviser comme ça
en ukraine est vécue complètement
séparément dans moi ce que j'aurais pu
poser comme questions à jérôme passer
d'une lui qui a couvert les deux camps
est ce qu'il ya un gros sentiment tenace
de part et d'autre ou est ce qu'il
existe encore aujourd'hui au stade au
moment où on en parle parce que ces deux
républiques existe à l'est et puis y'a
l'ouest est ce que ces deux camps sont
irréconciliables au niveau des
populations ou non non moi c'est ce qui
m'a beaucoup choqué moi ce que je ne
connaissais pas du tout d'ukraine
première fois c'était en février 2014
quand j'ai couvert maidan et très vite
je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait une une
fracture mais vraiment très profonde
a l'impression de franchir à chaque fois
que je partais j'arrivais à kiev j'ai
des amis à kiev et que je disais je vais
dans le donbass il me disait mais tu es
fou tu vas chez les sauvages suivent
ashley tu vas te faire tuer il faut pas
aller là bas enfin l'impression qu'il ya
deux réalités de pays de réalité qui ne
se connaissent pas qui ne se parlent pas
quand vous parliez de ça il n'y avait
pas encore cette division c'était à
maidan et vous alliez dans le drogba
s'il n'est pas encore de séparation
bassam à hamadan n'était pas aussi
évident mais on sentait qu'il y avait
déjà des kiev les premières
manifestations maidan il faut savoir
aussi que la vie bon nous on a vu les
manifestations depuis l'occident d'une
certaine façon qu un côté un peu
romantique mais pour les gens du donbass
il avait une tout autre lecture des
événements pour eux
le maïdan c'était quelque chose qui leur
a fait peur en fait puisque ça rappelait
bon les mouvements anti soviétique de la
seconde guerre mondiale qui
réapparaissait enfin le nazisme créé
nationalisé par fournier rares et tout
acte heymans est pas de même des rats et
pour eux ils ont vraiment pris peur
alors après ils ont été peut-être
conditionné aussi par la certaine
propagande mais il y avait déjà au
départ de toute façon une certaine
méfiance de part et d'autre aujourd'hui
est ce que vous estimez que ici en
occident on a une forme de vision
extrêmement manichéenne de de ce dossier
ukrainien
oui je trouve un peu mois maintenant
mais je me souviens en 2014 c'était
c'était très huit mannequins il y avait
d'un côté les
les gentils donc qui était pro européen
et de l'autre côté les méchants
qui était vendu enfin totalement soumis
à la russie ce qui est totalement enfin
moi j'ai pas vu ça
moi j'ai vu simplement dans le donbass
des personnes d'aidé beaucoup de civils
ont été victimes de d'attac de
bombardements et souvent justement les
gens me disais mais pourquoi vous les
journalistes vous parlais mal de nous
pourquoi vous dites qu'on ait des
ddd des des mains
mais
alors tout ce qu'on demande c'est de
vivre en paix on est des travailleurs
des gens modestes des mines beaucoup de
mineurs et voilà on ne manque de rien
j'ai jamais entendu de gens qui criaient
leur amour pour la russie pour la
lumière coaching c'est pas du tout ce
n'était pas du tout le cas on va
peut-être s'arrêter sur quelques photos
n'hésitez pas à re était bien vous allez
photo régis s'il vous plaît parce que ça
va avoir du mal évidemment les commenter
cet homme par exemple vous souvenez dans
quelles circonstances vous avez pris
cette photo donc c'était décembre 2014
dans la banlieue de donetsk et sur la
toute proche de l'aéroport où avaient
lieu des combats à l'aéroport et tout
autour il y avait des
pilonnages de l'artillerie de l'armée
ukrainienne et donc les habitants du
quartier vivaient dans les abris
souterrains soit des caves soit parfois
même des anciens abri de la seconde
guerre mondiale qui avait été réouvert
pour le pour ce conflit
aujourd'hui régis quand on voit les
photos de jérôme sessini son travail
qu'on entend ces témoignages
on imagine que l'attention doit être à
son comble en ukraine et que les gens ne
veulent surtout pas revivre
ça je crois que c'est ce qui est
intéressant en ce moment il y en a pas
mal de confrère jérôme et moi qui sont
là bas plutôt côté ukrainien est bon il
y à il ya une sorte d'attentes de
commandes de paix armée qui se met en
place avec des entraînements de civils
avec des kalachnikov en bois bref on
fait il ya tout un tas de mise le
conditionnement de la défense civile qui
se met en place mais on sent bien dans
les témoignages qui sont recueillis il y
en a eu quelques-uns aussi du côté du
côté des deux républiques du losc et de
deux nièces qu de l'autre côté
que personne n'a envie
qu'il y ait la guerre c'est assez
sensible les témoignages des gens qui
ont vécu 2014 je pense que j'ai on
pourrait nous peut-être vous m'éclairer
sur ce point mais mais le ces gens là
n'ont pas envie de revivre la même
expérience et on voit même que jusqu'au
président ukrainien qui dit aujourd'hui
d'arrêter des discours apocalyptiques et
qui s'est même engueulé avec joe biden
au téléphone en 10 ans américain arrêté
de parler d'imminence d'invasion parce
que nous c'est pas là on n'a pas la même
lecture ils ont conscience que leur pays
peut devenir un véritable champ de
bataille et ça ça peut durer pendant des
décennies que toute cette zone là
peut-être mise à genoux et je pense que
c'est
de ce qu'on entend de la part d'eads et
des ukrainiens de part et d'autre c'est
un peu ce message-là vouloir par et
jérôme sessini ben j'imagine que vous
avez gardé des contacts en ukraine
qu'est-ce qui vous disent effectivement
aujourd'hui donc je garde surtout des
contacts avec des amis à kiev avec le
don de basse je sais pas pourquoi c'est
plus compliqué
mais
il y à une certain il ya une espèce de
désillusions 600 de fatigue est vraiment
faim personne n'a envie de revivre la
guerre comme c'était le cas aujourd'hui
attendent beaucoup de ces négociations
une rencontre comme ça ils la suivent
avec attention et avec beaucoup d'espoir
ils attendent beaucoup des dirigeants
européens américains et russes
aujourd'hui oui évidemment c'est
exactement beaucoup ils attendent
surtout de
qui n'est pas d'escaladé que la guerre
ne reviennent pas vain la guerre est
toujours là mais on va laisser un
conflit gelé pour l'instant plus ou
moins mais ils ne veulent surtout pas de
guerre
moi je voulais je voulais vous demander
vous avez vous avez couvert la syrie
aussi il y avait les russes étaient
partie prenante
l'irak
comment l'ukraine est ce que c'est un
c'est un conflit à part dans votre
carrière qui et comment vous le jugez
par rapport aux autres guerre mais vous
avez couvertes alors d'abord c'était la
proximité
avec la france qui est qui est assez
important puisque ces quelques heures
d'avion de paris de craine mais c'est
aussi une guerre où j'ai pu vraiment
enfin tous ceux qui l'ont couvert comme
moi on a été témoin de la
de la construction un peu d'une guerre
c'est à dire ces parties de
manifestation
sur la place de maidan et petit à petit
on a vu comment le conflit s assit
transformant confirmait donc ça on a pu
le vivre
pratiquement au jour le jour et surtout
ce qui était très très prégnant pour moi
c'était là cette division
cette façon 20 de plus parler cette
structure qui a entre les deux les deux
ukraine
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez le
traitement des médias occidentaux même
de notre enfin voilà des médias en
général
qu'est ce que vous vous dites que
parfois
et peut-être hors sol par rapport à ce
qui se passe là bas sur le terrain il ya
un décalage ont finalement pas tant que
ça non ça dépend bon
moi j'ai toujours
faim j'ai toujours j'ai toujours un peu
peur quand j'entends les médias qui
parlent de façon peu trop véhémente
et qui va comme c'était le cas c'est le
cas actuellement qui parle d' escalade
de guerre
on a l'impression parfois qu'il qu'ils
attendent en fait qu'il a faim qu'ils la
veulent geppic n'ont peut-être pas
qu'ils la veulent mais
moi je feins
une dramatisation dramatisation voit la
dramatisation d'autre
part ajouté moi j'ai couvert quelques
conflits et je me dis toujours à chaque
fois c'est vrai qu'il ya sept cette
rhétorique qu'on entend qui a tendance à
se répéter ce espèce d'exaltation de
certains jeunes et les journalistes sont
pas indemme parce qu'il y en a qui
écrivent avec des accents pas qu'ils
souhaitent la guerre mais en tout cas
qui qui vous sont l'impression qu'elle
va être inéluctable et quand on va sur
le terrain et au fil des années on a
toujours ce recul et on se dit
finalement bas c'est toujours les mêmes
qui qui déclenche les guerres et c'est
toujours et jamais ce qui les
déclenchent qui les terminent et et de
voir ces photos là aujourd'hui et les
conséquences ou encore de ce conflit
s'était 2014 on est en 2022 c'était donc
il ya huit ans et pendant huit ans
depuis huit ans l'ukraine est un pays
qui a du mal à se relever parce qu'il ya
eu ce conflit et on voudrait qu'il y en
ait encore un autre fan et je dis pas
qu'on voudrait qu'il y en ait encore un
autre mais c'est toujours moi j'ai
toujours un sérieux doute sur
ces guerres qu'on a déclenché un depuis
l'afghanistan jusqu'à la libye quand on
voit les conséquences aujourd'hui de ces
guerres quand on retourne dans ces pays
là on voit des pays anéantis et bien on
n'a surtout pas envie vraiment parce que
on a vu ça
de revoir la même chose et en
particulier dans une zone comme
d'ukraine qui est comme le disait jérôme
très proche de nous très proche de
l'europe ça serait dommageable pour tout
le monde merci beaucoup régis le sommier
jérôme sessini d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france